Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We are here to answer a simple question: what
is peer review?
Well, in science, making sure that the validity
of published results is beyond doubt is of
utmost importance.
To this end, many scientific journals and
conferences exist where researchers can submit
their findings in the form of a science paper.
As a condition of acceptance, these papers
shall undergo extensive scrutiny by typically
2 to 5 other scientists.
This refereeing process we call peer review.
Single blind reviewing means that the names
of the reviewers are shrouded in mystery,
but the authors of the paper are known to
them.
In double blind reviews, however, the papers
are anonymized, and none of the parties know
the names of each other.
These different kinds of blind reviews were
made to eliminate possible people-related
biases.
There is a lot of discussion whether they
do a good job at that or not, but this is
what they are for.
After the review, if the results are found
to be correct, and the reviews are favorable
enough, the paper is accepted and subsequently
published in a journal and/or presented at
a conference.
Usually, the higher the prestige of a publication
venue is, the higher the likelihood of rejection,
which inevitably raises a big question: how
to choose the papers that are to be accepted?
As we are scientists, we have to try to ensure
that the peer review is a fair and consistent
process.
To measure if this is the case, the NIPS experiment
was born.
NIPS is one of the highest quality conferences
in machine learning with a remarkably low
acceptance ratio, which typically hovers below
25%.
This is indeed remarkably low considering
the fact that many of the best research groups
in the world submit their finest works here.
So here is the astute idea behind the NIPS
experiment: a large amount of papers would
be secretly disseminated to multiple committees,
they would review it without knowing about
each other, and we would have a look whether
they would accept or reject the same papers.
Re-reviewing papers and see if the results
is the same, if you will.
At a given prescribed acceptance ratio, there
was a disagreement for 57% of the papers.
This means that one of the committees would
accept the paper and the other wouldn't, and
vice versa.
Now, to put this number into perspective,
the mathematical model of a random committee
was put together.
This means that the members of this committee
have no idea what they are doing, and as a
review, they basically toss up a coin and
accept or reject the paper based on the result.
The calculations conclude that this random
committee would have this disagreement ratio
of about 77%.
This is hardly something to be proud of: the
consistency of expert reviewers is significantly
closer to a coinflip than to a hypothetical
perfect review process.
So, experts, 57% disagreement, Coinflip Committee,
77% disagreement.
It is not as bad as the Coinflip Committee,
so the question naturally arises: where are
the differences?
Well, it seems that the top 10% of the papers
are clearly accepted by both committees, the
bottom 25% of the papers are clearly rejected,
this is the good news, and the bad news is
that anything between might as well be decided
with a cointoss.
If the consistency of peer review is subject
to maximization, we clearly have to do something
different.
Huge respect for the NIPS organizers for doing
this laborious experiment, for the reviewers
who did a ton of extra work, and kudos for
the fact that the organizers were willing
to release such uncomfortable results.
This is very important, and is the only way
of improving our processes.
Hopefully, someday we shall have our revenge
over the Coinflip Committee.
Can we do something about this?
What is a possible solution?
Well, of course, this is a large and difficult
problem for which I don't pretend to have
any perfect solutions, but there is a really
interesting idea by a renowned professor about
crowdsourcing reviews that I found to be spectacular.
I'll leave the blog post in the comments section
both for this and the NIPS experiment, and
we shall have an entire episode about this
soon.
Stay tuned!
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!